NATASHA ROMANOFF
You don't know everything about me.
The Avengers weren't my first family.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
It's important for us to understand
how this family has
shaped the person that Natasha became.
MELINA VOSTOKOFF
Natasha, don't slouch.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I'm not slouching.
ALEXEI SHOSTAKOV
Listen to your mother.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Oh my God. This...
ALEXEI SHOSTAKOV
Op, op...
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Alright, enough, all of you.
YELENA BELOVA
I didn't say anything.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
Yelena is the, kind of,
"little sister" character.
FLORENCE PUGH
She's there to get the job done.
Her relationship with Natasha then becomes
quite interesting because they're
constantly butting heads in
the way that siblings do.
YELENA BELOVA
Why do you always do that thing?
NATASHA ROMANOFF
What thing?
YELENA BELOVA
The pose! It's a fighting pose.
You're a total poser.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
It's really fun to be able to see those
two characters
when they're together.
YELENA BELOVA
Such a poser.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
It's good to see you too, sis.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
It was so wonderful to be able to do this
with Florence because
she's such a wonderful actor.
Feisty and fiery,
and just full of life.
FLORENCE PUGH
Scarlett's been the leading female face
of these films for 10 years.
That's definitely a cool badge to wear.
I remember her daughter
came to set one day and I was like,
"What does she think you do?" and she goes
"Oh you know, fight baddies for a living."
And I was like,
"But that is what you do!"
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I like your vest.
YELENA BELOVA
God, I knew it. I knew you did.
It's so cool, right?